Hi, Dr. Cutters. I paid for 10 sessions of photo-dynamic therapy last year,
when no cancer was detected in my body. Hoping that photo-dynamic therapy would help
keep it away, but it didn't. The cancer grew, buried in photo-dynamic therapy treatments.
I have about five sessions left. It's important to finish out the sessions,
or do you think it's better to ask to use the money towards other services products
that the doctor offers? He sent me links talking about efficacy of photo-dynamic therapy,
but I don't know if I'm being taken advantage of or not. I'll send you the links for review.
What do you think? Photo-dynamic therapy can be beneficial for different people. Now,
understand, and I have talked about this more with photo-dynamic therapy, is photo-dynamic therapy
is a broad term. It's kind of like saying I'm doing the right machine.
Well, which right machine? Because you can call anything a right machine, and it doesn't necessarily
mean it's a machine that's using light frequencies. It doesn't mean that it's a frequency that
has enough amperage to actually penetrate your body. It doesn't mean that you're using
a machine that is programmable to the frequencies of your cancer. There's a lot of
same thing with photo-dynamic therapy. So, photo-dynamic therapy is basically anything that's
usually laser falls into that category. It really depends on the machine that they're doing,
but even that, let's say if I was doing something and during that process, let's say I was doing
chemotherapy and during chemotherapy my cancer grew, then why would I continue the same chemotherapy?
You know, I would think that it would be a hint to maybe think about switching up therapies. No,
maybe you can argue that I didn't do enough. I didn't do it often enough. I didn't do it.
There's different variables that may need to be addressed, but I would definitely say that
in this case, be an alternative therapy, I would switch to something else personally.
So, I would switch to maybe an IV therapy or something like that.